he to resist charlie's we found a gun
official series premiere date for
Sherlock series 3 so I thought I do a
quick update with my top five things to
look for two in the new season
along with the other videos that i'm
gonna be doing be sure to subscribe to
get everything
I'm also going to be doing a special
holiday giveaway in the next couple of
weeks
but important things first so people in
the UK
you will be able to watch episode 1
Sherlock season three starting January
1st
each new episode 2&3 will premiere each
week after that
people everywhere else including North
America will have to wait till January
19th for the first episode
so he was going to happen because I'm
going to be watching starting January
1st
I'll be posting review videos right
after each episode airs I'll try not to
go too crazy with spoilers
but I'll be doing at least one to two
videos per week but it comes back
also be doing somebody shot videos in
December to help us get ready
in case you haven't seen it I've already
done actual spoiler video for season 3 I
have a link to that at the end of the
video as well as in the description but
now hear my top five things look for to
ensure like series 3
number five the fall so listening to
showing explain exactly how he survived
at the end of season two
is going to be amazing whenever sure
like explains things they also use some
really cool looking graphics on screen
to
to show his mind palace as it were in
the time line series three picks up two
years after the events of the season 2
finale
so Watson has moved on and it's going to
be a very tense reunion because he
believes sure like to be dead this whole
time
number four sure lally so like I said
Watson believes Sherlock was dead this
whole time
so when he finds out he was alive he's
not too happy that means the charlotte
has to find someone else to go out on
crime scenes with them
enter Molly Hooper she's also an
integral part to him faking his death at
the end a season 2
number three the mustache so if you've
seen the trailers you have seen
what the new sporting the most
spectacular I've mustaches and no he is
not celebrating Movember
remember it's been two years so there's
been a lot of changes in his life but
you can expect a big part they're eating
it to revolve around mustache related
comedy
number two the ladies in Sherlock slight
so the success
sure like as a show as well as a
character is really dependent upon the
strait that the supporting characters
and charlotte has some amazing women in
his life obviously there's missus
attorney Molly Hooper who I already
talked about
but there's Irene Adler and now molly
moore stand in this season
those last two are actually really
important for this new season as well as
going for
Laura over the actress who played Irene
in season 2 said that she might be
coming back
she didn't say whether she was talking
about season 3 or season 4 but my more
stan is going to be sure what's new
best frenemy in this new season we won't
be hurt on the second episode
and I don't include too many spoilers
but if you want to find out about her
you can watch that spoil the video I did
needless to say sure looks relationship
with her
will become very tense and very
uncomfortable in the best possible way
and my number one thing to look for to
the season in Sherlock the villain
so the new billing is Charles Augustus
menus and his name is actually a
reference to a Conan Doyle the name
Charles Augustus Milverton
who is gonna described as like that Cena
blackmailers so that my community of
what he'll be doing a sherlock in this
new season
Steven Moffat to find him is terrifying
so he's going to be a lot of fun to
watch
but now that you have some info about
the new season let me know in the
comments were you most excited to see
i'm looking for to the reunion is going
to be very punchy in very hilarious
so update on this week most the shows I
do are back to normal
back to the normal schedule so all the
regular videos I do will be normal this
week
tonight is the midseason finale %uh the
walking dead you can click here to get
that video I the inefficiencies that was
the video later tonight any
click here to get that Sherlock spoiler
video that I mentioned earlier thank you
so much watching
of the guys tonight advise